[Music]
what i can't believe as i found out just
about an hour before the interview one
of the producers mentioned to me that
you're a grandmother i am a kid
not a grandmother let's get it correct
it's a glam mom glam
now it says here grandmother
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so you're a grandma i'm a glam mom okay
very nice when you're this young and
this fabulous it's called glam mom and i
have a beautiful glam baby
okay
well don't let kelsey grammar diaper it
that's all i want to say
[Laughter]
huh
uh now there was no audition for the new
normal the show that you're on now there
was no audition no the the producer just
wanted you yes
and wha wha what did he see that
convinced him you were the right one for
the role um when i i first met ryan
murphy uh he he called me up and said hi
i'd like for you to come and um work on
glee and play this character coach ross
washington
and he said to me that i saw you on
celebrity apprentice and i've watched
you on housewives and i don't think
there's anyone that can take on two
sylvester who is aka jane lynch better
than you can so he wanted someone strong
enough to go against jane lynch yeah and
jane also was six feet tall right and so
i came on and i did coach ross
washington and then after that uh he
said to me i want you to play this
character rocky i'm the new normal and i
was like okay sure i didn't ask any
questions didn't read a script and he
just basically offered it to me and so
and here i am well good for you well
thanks so much for coming you looking
gorgeous very nice to finally meet you
nice to meet you as well uh the new
normal premieres in its regular time
slot tomorrow night at 9 30 on nbc nene
leakes thanks so much for being here
guys